my deepest apologies to many key
decision-makers and so many members of
the general public you can kick this
stuff around it's it's not nearly as bad
as they thought right here in midtown
Manhattan guys you were working off the
same information we were working off you
made a lot of tough decisions expecting
us to get it right and we didn't once
again I'm sorry look we're not gonna
hike what's happening here but um not
that bad but his caption is yeah he
wanted more he's a little disappointed
if the forecast has to be wrong I'd
rather it be overestimated but I'm sorry
it ended up this way put simply we got
about half as much as what a lot of the
projections had been the Euro model the
most reliable of them all has failed
will the city see a foot of snow
probably but all of us have failed to an
extent even just looking behind me too i
see taxis going up and down Fifth Avenue
where the forecasters do the best they
can I do not criticize weather
forecasters I learned still blame is on
us as meteorologists can't be placed
anywhere else it is a difficult day for
us any time a forecast does not work out
you